les pandémies questionne à chaque fois
notre rapport à l'animal qu'ils soient
sauvages ou domestiques ainsi que notre
modèle agricole et notre système de
santé
ce n'est pas sans fierté que je vous
présente en ce jour au nom du groupe
écologie solidarité territoire une
proposition de loi qui répond à une
prise de conscience grandissante quant
aux conditions parfois déplorables
d'élevage des animaux dans notre système
agricole
j'ajouterai à titre liminaire que ce
texte a reçu le soutien de nombreuses
associations de défense des droits à
nîmes des animaux mais aussi
l'assentiment de sénateurs et sénatrices
membres de six groupes politiques
différentes que je tiens à remercier a
remercié ses dires la résonance globale
de ce sujet dans notre société
au delà des clivages partisans l'élevage
intensif est vivement critiqué
relativement au bien-être animal à la
qualité de la viande ainsi qu'aux
conditions de travail des professionnels
et à son modèle en france 80% des
animaux sont dans des élevages intensifs
cette proportion est particulièrement
élevé pour les ports 95% et les
volailles 80% des poulets de chair et
68% des poules pondeuses ces animaux
séduisent dans les fermes usines des
traitements cruels et parfois
intolérables il se trouve confiné sans
accès à des espaces en plein air souvent
dans des cages ce qui entraîne chez eux
des troubles comportementaux ex m
les élevages publicité asphyxie
en août les productions locales qui ont
vu leur nombre baisser drastiquement ces
dernières années ce sont alors les
agriculteurs un même qui pâtissent
grandement depuis non rémunérateurs
associé à des conditions de travail
difficiles contribuant lourdement au
mal-être du monde agricole
c'est pourquoi des fins de promotion
d'un modèle d'agriculture paysanne
favorisons une alimentation locale
respectueuse de la nature et soucieuse
du bien-être de l'animal mais aussi de
ses acteurs du monde paysan
il apparaît nécessaire d'accompagner ces
derniers dans la transition vers un
élevage un abattage éthiques
à cet égard il convient particulièrement
d'accompagner ceux qui dépendent
aujourd'hui de l'élevage intensif
enfants de la fin de leur permet de
faire évoluer leurs pratiques
selon un sondage ifop de janvier 2021
85% des français se déclarent opposés à
l'élevage intensif
signe que l'opinion publique est
favorable à la mise en place de cette
nécessaire transition
cette évolution de l'opinion nous la
devons aussi au travail des lanceurs
dalet et aux actions des associations au
niveau européen la directive 98 flash 58
soit chez eux ayant trait à la
protection des animaux dans les élevages
peuvent les blondes principe du
bien-être chez les animaux domestiques
de production tous les états membres
concernant les bâtiments infrastructures
la liberté de mouvement
l'alimentation les mutilations les
maltraitances elle n'en détaille pas
cependant la mise à neuf et laisse aux
états membres une large marge d'action
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat que je salue ici ainsi que sa
présidente et sa rapporteure avec qui
j'ai eu le plaisir travailler à rejeter
cette ppl se contentant de cette
directive qui en fait laisse la france
l'appliqué à sa convenance et je le
regrette
en termes de législation en la matière
la france accuse hélas un grand retard
par rapport au nombre de ses voisins
européens
97% des animaux sont élevés aux cages en
autriche en suède ce sont 92 % des
animaux qui sont élevées en cage tandis
que l'allemagne obtient la quatrième le
quatrième meilleur score de la
communauté avec un taux de 86 % suivis
par les belgique pays bas et la belgique
avec des taux respectifs de 83% et 69%
la france elle n'arrive qu'en 17ème
position de ce classement avec un score
de 25 à 100 derrière la roumanie la
croatie et la hongrie
nous devons instaurer en europe un
étiquetage alimente un transparent
comprenant descriptive classe du mode
d'élevage de sauf que le consommateur
citoyen puisse pleinement jouer son rôle
dans la protection du bien-être animal
ainsi que de sa santé et de
l'environnement sans léser bien sûr
économiquement les agriculteurs qui
doivent pouvoir résister à l'importation
de pays qui ne suivent pas le même
cahier de charges en terme de conditions
similaires de bien-être animal et de
respect de l'environnement par exemple
par une taxation
les agriculteurs sont les premiers à
pâtir de l'élevage industriel déjà au
niveau économique avec la réduction du
nombre d'exploitations avec la
concentration en clément
et plus puissante d'élevage toujours
plus importants quant au niveau éthique
et moral je le rappelle les agriculteurs
m leurs bêtes et voudrait s'assurer de
pouvoir leur donner autant que possible
en de limay une bonne mort sans
souffrance cette belle étant donné la
relative brièveté du temps de débat
qu'il y ait tant partie n'aborde pas la
question de l'abattage en détails tout
en soulignant les vertus possible à cet
égard de l'abattage de proximité son
article premier temps garanti
progressivement un accès extérieur une
surface par tête adapté en tenant compte
des moments de vie de l'animal et des
cas spécifiques géographique ou
climatiques comme les élevages en
montagne avec un moratoire jusqu'à 2040
avec une mise en place progressive des
dispositifs d'accès au plein air et des
seuils de densité maximale dès 2025
l'article 2 limite la durée de transport
des animaux à 8h sur le territoire
national dans des conditions assurant
leur bien-être
l'article 3 interdit l'élimination sauf
en cas d'épizootie des poussins mâles et
dépendantes on fume elles vivent broyé
et tout fait gazer les poussins mâles
sont victimes d'un cauchemar industriel
qui est hélas toujours une réalité en
france
l'allemagne confirme s'appuie position
de pionnière dans la lutte contre le
broyage et le gazage des pousses ammann
a interdit à partir de 2022 cette
pratique
le projet de loi a été validée vendredi
dernier
par le bund assad le sexage in ovo sera
pratiqué en amont entre le 9e et le
quatorzième jour pour déterminer le sexe
des embryons
parallèlement cette méthode appelée
sellette existe une autre technique de
sexage in ovo française par
spectrophotométrie mais encore inaboutie
en france on observe certes quelques
timides avancées
le ministère de l'agriculture annonce
l'interdiction de l'élimination des
poussins pour 2022 fin 2022 21 pardon
faut-il encore que cette promesse soit
tenue
la filiale d eux annonce qu'elle ne sera
pas prête pour cette date mais se
prépare timidement à se lancer dans le
déploiement du sexage in ovo nous
demandons quant à nous l'application dès
janvier 2022
le passage à l'élevage et il nécessite
l'accompagnement financier des
agriculteurs notre note ex prévoit pour
cette raison un fonds pour leur
permettent de transformer leurs
activités et de se conformer au nouveau
cadre juridique y compris pour
développer l'abattage de proximité la
puissance publique un rôle crucial à
jouer dans la transition écologique
subventionner leurs investissements par
déplaire à taux zéro ou garantis par
l'état figure parmi les quelques
solutions envisageables
notre pays vit une urgence sociale sa
mi-temps climatiques et
environnementales il vit aussi dans une
chance éthiques
nos jeunes défilant nombreux dans nos
rues pour le climat ne cesse de nous le
rappeler
il est donc primordial mes chers
collègues d'engager sans délai cette
démarche vers un modèle respectueux du
vivant je remercie mr
chaque collègue la parole est à madame
marie christine chauvin
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier le groupe
écologiste d'avoir inscrit cette
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour du
sénat nous permettant d'avoir un débat
de société sur le thème du bien-être
animal
je crois que tous les parlementaires ici
je dis bien tous partagent vos
préoccupations
les bonnes pratiques pour l'élevage le
transport et l'abattage sont un souci de
tous les jours qui prendra une place de
plus en plus importante dans les années
à venir car la société le veut les
filières le veulent et c'est bien normal
tous les parlementaires comme toutes les
filières veulent tendre vers plus
d'élevage alternatif à la cage ou au
bâtiment
nous voulons tous améliorer les
conditions de transport des animaux
c'est un sujet consensuel ce que
démontre d'ailleurs l'adoption très
large et trans partisane de résolution
du parlement européen sur le sujet enfin
il faut bien entendu trouver une
solution viable au broyage massive de
pouce être c'est justement pourquoi la
commission partage pleinement vos
objectifs
mais elle conteste fermement les moyens
retenus et surtout les effets de bords
importants induits par la rédaction de
la proposition de loi
je voudrais avant d'analyser dans le
détail la proposition de loi commencé
mon propos en ayant une pensée pour les
éleveurs car s'il ya le bien-être animal
il y à aussi il y a surtout le bien-être
des éleveurs les deux sujets sont
d'ailleurs souvent étroitement liés
se lever tôt le matin pour perdre de
l'argent personne ne peut le supporter
c'est ce qui explique que la
décapitalisation du cheptel
se poursuivre dans certaines filières si
la situation perdure
notre souveraineté alimentaire en
élevage est menacée d'autant plus que
les importations sont déjà très
présentes 45 % de notre consommation de
poulet 25% pour le port 55% pour les
ovins et un tiers de nos produits
laitiers or si rien n'est fait nous
perdrons les externalités positives de
notre élevage en matière d'aménagement
du territoire de stockage de carbone de
réduction de la vulnérabilité aux aléas
naturels de bio diversité des races
cultiver ce contexte devait être rappelé
pour garder à l'esprit qu'il faut être à
l'écouté de nos éleveurs lors de nos
auditions tous nous ont affirmé ne pas
comprendre pourquoi ils sont toujours
voué aux gémonies sans que leurs efforts
ne soient valorisés il faut le redire le
bien-être animal c'est tous les jours en
agriculture il y a bien entendu quelques
situations anormales ait des abus des
exemples existent je le nez je le nos
lignes je ne le nie pas excusez moi mais
c'est comme dans toute profession
prenons l'exemple des poules pondeuses
l'élevage alternatif à la cage est
désormais majoritaire alors qu'il
n'était que de 20 % il y a dix ans des
élevages expérimentaux se développe pour
éviter l'élevage de lapins en cage
rappelons aussi que 94% des vaches
laitières et 67% des vaches allaitantes
aux accès à l'extérieur en matière de
volaille la france est la première
d'europe avec un taux de 20% élevé en
plein air le second pays européen n'est
seulement qu'à 5%
toutes les filières interprofessionnelle
se sont engagés dans un plan bien être
animal et développe des outils de
diagnostic bien-être animal sur les
exploitations afin de mieux mesurer les
progrès
réalisé cette situation doit être dans
tous nos esprits alors d'examiner les
propositions pour interdire certaines
pratiques d'élevage de transport ou
d'abattage ces rappels et o2 était
d'autant plus nécessaire que le titre de
la proposition de loi ignore cette
réalité en plaidant pour un élevage
éthique juste socialement et soucieux du
bien-être animal
il est sous-entendu qu'il n'existe pas
d'élevage éthique et soucieux du
bien-être animal
aujourd'hui en france je veux le dire
clairement
cela ne correspond pas à la réalité du
terrain agricole
la proposition de loi pose également des
difficultés pratiques sur l'élevage
plein air par exemple l'article 1 entend
interdire toute construction de nouveaux
bâtiments d'élevage ne prévoyant pas un
accès à l'extérieur des animaux à
compter de 2026 est d'interdire tout
élevage et d'interdire tout élevage hors
plein air à l'horizon 2040 soit mais les
instituts techniques et des filières
rappelle que cette généralisation pause
les difficultés en matière de bien-être
animal pour certaines espèces ainsi que
des interrogations en matière de
biosécurité
on l'a vu avec l'influenza aviaire
récemment le tout plein elle expose à
davantage de risques épidémiques notre
résilience et notre souveraineté se joue
aussi dans la complémentarité de nos
élevages non dans leur opposition
j'ajoute que le plein air impliquerait
la mise en place d'un parcours pour les
animaux qui est fortement consommateur
de foncier rien que pour le port le
passage au tout plein air en 2040
représente une consommation foncière
équivalente à un département français
pour les poules pondeuses
il faudrait trouver l'équivalent de la
surface de la ville de paris quand on
connaît les difficultés liées à
l'artificialisation des sols
je crois que ces chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes il en va de même pour la
proposition visant à plafonner les temps
de transport c'est une fausse solution
un vrai problème celui du manque
maillage territorial suffisant pour les
aborde les labos les abattoirs
excusez-moi de proximité qui est un vrai
débat j'ajoute que la proposition
d'article de conformément au droit
européen ne réglemente les durées de
transport que sur le territoire national
dès lors si un camion traverser une
frontière
la réglementation française ne lui sera
plus à pic
applicable et il bénéficiera d'une
réglementation européenne moins dix ans
il serait donc pertinent économiquement
de s'approvisionner auprès d'abattoirs
étrange les faisant faire plus de route
à nos animaux je crois que c'est le
contraire de l'effet visés par la loi
de même les bassins de production sont
parfois très éloignés des abattoirs où
des couvoirs en limitant la durée des
transports à 4h pour la volaille est le
lapin par exemple dont les abattoirs et
les couvoirs sont presque exclusivement
dans l'ouest on s'interdirait à tout
élevage ailleurs que sans que dans sept
régions en france est ainsi que nous
favoriserons les circuits courts et la
diversification de notre agriculture
de plus la commission des affaires
économiques a estimé que l'échelon
d'action n'était pas la bonne
car le tout doit être portée au niveau
européen à défaut on alourdira encore
les contraintes de nos agriculteurs
français tout en exportant les pratiques
que la loi condamne rats chez nos
voisins ce qui se traduira par davantage
d'importations de denrées cela ne fera
aucun gagnant en matière de bien être
animal réduira notre souveraineté
alimentaire ainsi que le bilan
environnemental de notre alimentation
j'en veux pour preuve la délicate
question du broyage est du gazage des
poussins mâles et des canetons femelles
les techniques de recherche du sexage
dans l'oeuf ont considérablement évolué
et permettent d'envisager effectivement
de tourner la page du broyage à court
terme
oui il faut s'en féliciter mais elle
impose et intégralement dans huit mois
c'est condamner des petits coups voir et
c'est surtout renchérir le
ou des ovoproduits issus d'élevages
français qui représentent 40 % de la
production totale
or pour ces produits l'aspect prix est
essentielle allé trop loin
nous renforcerons la compétitivité des
ovoproduits polonais qui inonderait
notre marché alors que les poussins
là-bas continuerait à être broyés pour
le broyage des poussins je crois qu'il
faut faire confiance aux accouveurs le
marché est prêt la recherche évoluent et
se perfectionne je suis sûr que nous y
parviendrons dans un pas de temps
rapides les filières ont d'ailleurs
renouveler leur en agde leurs
engagements sur le fco qui à très court
terme
faisons leur confiance l'union
européenne doit nous faire
collectivement évolué pour limiter les
distorsions de concurrence et que ces
mesures soient réellement efficace alors
monsieur le ministre je vous interroge
quels sont les engagements du
gouvernement
est ce que le gouvernement est prêt à
porter en la matière au niveau européen
pour que ensemble nous avancions dans
cette amélioration mais ensemble
enfin j'entends bien sûr les critiques
de certains trouvant au contraire que la
loi est équilibrée dans la mesure où
elle prévoit une compensation par un
fond des pertes induites par la présente
proposition de loi je tenais à leur dire
que j'ai moi même
on a eu ce sentiment en première analyse
je soutiendrai toujours ces mécanismes
incitatifs d'accompagnement à des
mécanismes d'interdît d'interdiction
sans aide
toutefois l'analyse a démontré que ce
fonds était irréaliste car les chiffres
de cirque ou des surcoûts induits par la
proposition de loi sont colossaux rien
que pour le port le surcoût du plein air
est estimé à 13 milliards d'euros le
surcoût du broyage pour les seuls poules
pondeuses ses 64 millions de votes soit
4% du chiffre d'affaires de la filière
quand on sait que l'agriculture a été
dotée d'un 1,2 milliard
au total dans le plan de relance je
m'interroge sur la faisabilité d'un tel
fonds le risque étant que les
compensations soient bien inférieurs ce
qui pénaliserait alors considérablement
le revenu de nos agriculteurs
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que la
commission propose de rejeter cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci madame leur
porter la parole est à monsieur alain
griset ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises
monsieur le ministre
la même la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques paname la rapporteure
permettez moi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
permettez moi tout d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser l'absence de julien de
normandie pris par la négociation finale
de la pac à bruxelles une échéance
majeure pour la totalité de nos
agriculteurs
chacun sait ici que le bien-être animal
et le respect de l'environnement sont
des sujets majeurs pour nos concitoyens
sur ces questions les débats point trop
souvent du doigt les éleveurs français
alors qu'ils sont les premiers à
souhaiter plus de bien être animal en
faisant le pari de la modernisation des
infrastructures d'élevage et d'abattage
le gouvernement agit avec méthode et
pragmatisme
aux côtés de nos éleveurs pour leur
donner les moyens de répondre aux
attentes sociétales
ces sujets de long terme nécessite une
politique d'accompagnement et non pas
des bouleversements radicaux
le sujet est celui de la transition
d'élevage que nos concitoyens attendent
et je sais que dans cet hémicycle vous
ne l'aborderons pas sous le seul prisme
de l'émotion mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice benbassa soyez en
assuré le gouvernement partagent la même
ambition d'améliorer les conditions
d'élevage de transport ou d'abattage au
sein de la grande ferme france le
gouvernement aborde les enjeux de
transition avec raison et pragmatisme
nous devons répondre aux impératifs
biologiques des espèces et définir
collectivement les modalités les plus
adaptées pour répondre bien être des
animaux lutter contre la maltraitance
animale et garantir des produits
alimentaires sains et de qualité car ils
fine l élevage et là ne l'oublions pas
pour nous nourrir
si l'on peut comprendre le souhait de
nombreux citoyens de permettre aux
animaux d'élevage de vivre en plein air
les débats doivent tenir compte des
enjeux sanitaires économiques de foncier
de reconversion de souveraineté
nationale dans les débats trop souvent
passionnées sur la question animale
en premier lieu je souhaite rappeler que
les élevages français sont à taille
humaine
bien loin des élevages industriels qui
existe ailleurs dans le monde
ensuite l'élevage français et là des
plus durable au monde et les filières
met tout en oeuvre pour assurer la
transition agroécologiques les plans de
filière mise en place à partir de 2017
ont déjà prouvé leur efficacité sur le
plan sanitaire
prenant l'exemple de la lutte contre
l'antibiorésistance le plan porté par le
ministère de l'agriculture a porté ses
fruits avec une réduction de 37 % des
utilisations d'antibiotiques en cinq ans
l'exposition des animaux aux
antibiotiques en france est inférieur à
la moyenne européenne
assurer un minimum d'accès plein air à
tous les animaux d'élevage dès 2040
n'est pas raisonnable prenons
actuellement quelques exemples plein air
représente aujourd'hui cinq personnes la
production aujourd'hui c'est 90% de la
production de poulets de chair qu'il
faudrait repenser en france il n'y a pas
un modèle unique d'élevage et c'est
d'ailleurs là notre richesse cette
ambition de montée en gamme qui est
portée au travers de cette ppl nous
pouvons et nous devons tous la soutenir
car elle permettra une plus juste
rémunération des producteurs mais
laissait croire qu'en 20 ans nous
n'aurons plus aucun poulet ni port
standard dans nos fermes et fo est
contre-productif si cette ambition n'est
pas réfléchi à l'échelle du marché
unique et des relations commerciales
internationales
le temps de l'agriculture est long il
faut assurer des transitions adapté au
marché sans quoi nous serons rapidement
confrontés à une augmentation de
produits importés à moindre coût venant
de pays qui ne respectent pas nos
pratiques
et notamment des viandes qui proviennent
d'élevages très intensifs le débat du
transport des animaux vivants doit
également s'inscrire dans cette
réflexion a minima européenne pour
éviter tout effet de concurrence
déloyale au détriment des opérateurs qui
travaillaient exclusivement sur le
territoire national c'est d'ailleurs
ainsi que la présidence actuelle du lieu
envisagé que la stratégie farm tout fort
que la firme nous allons pour parra mais
pardon nous allons par ailleurs
améliorer les dispositions relatives au
transport par voie maritime
comme nous nous y sommes engagés début
2000 ventes dans le courant de cette
année sans qu'une modification
législative soit nécessaire j'ajouterai
également que le plan de relance et son
volet modernisation des abattoirs
favorisera aussi des filières locales et
donc aura un effet indirect bénéfique
sur le transport des animaux vivants sur
le sujet des transitions et de
l'amélioration du bien-être animal la
fin du broyage des poussins est un
exemple concret des enjeux auxquels nous
devons répondre la filière le lme
couvoir principaux impactés par cette
transition a bien intégré l objectif l
attente des citoyens en la matière le
sujet de la formalisation de
l'interdiction et finalement aujourd'hui
secondaire car des méthodes
opérationnelles existent l'enjeu c'est
de savoir qui paye le coût de cette
transition l'état au travers du plan de
relance peut initier des changements en
finançant une partie des investissements
mais un modèle pérenne ne peut pas
reposer exclusivement sur l'état le coût
de la transition implique également des
changements de pratiques au quotidien la
filière travaille sur une feuille de
route opérationnelle inscrire une mesure
d'interdiction dans la loi ne
permettrait en outre pas d'accompagner
financièrement ces filières et nous
pouvons par ailleurs d'ores et déjà le
faire sur le plan réglementaire au
travers par exemple d'un décret je tiens
à rappeler
je sais qu'ici beaucoup en ont
conscience
qu'au cours des dernières années nous
avons imposé énormément de nouvelles
contraintes aux éleveurs français pour
répondre aux attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens restons sur l'exemple criant
de la filière poules pondeuses en 2012
les éleveurs ont investi massivement
dans se mettre aux normes
et certains n'ont pas fini de payer les
traites de leur emprunt la loi et galim
et les plans du filière qui en découlent
ont interdit la mise en production de
tout bâtiment d'élevage en cage et nous
sommes déjà plus de 53% de poules
pondeuses élevé en systèmes alternatifs
à la cage ces transitions toujours des
coûts et les éleveurs ne peuvent seuls
les assumer il faut accompagner les
transitions que nous imposons en
agriculture au risque de mettre en
grande difficulté économique et
psychologique des éleveurs la clé réside
dans la montée en gamme
car elle seule permet de répondre aux
attentes sociétales tout en offrant une
meilleure rémunération aux éleveurs
c'est tout le sens de notre action
les états généraux de l'alimentation ont
permis d'améliorer la structuration des
filières avait des exigences accrues en
termes de respect de l'environnement et
du bien-être animal reposant sur des
signes de qualité
je tiens ici à saluer la
responsabilisation des professionnels
qui se sont organisés autour de plans de
filières et de charte de bonnes
pratiques pour répondre aux attentes
sociétales une véritable transition est
en marche toute transition a un coût et
nécessite un accompagnement réfléchi si
tout le sens du plan france relance qui
consacre près de 300 millions d'euros à
la modernisation de nos élevages et de
nos abattoirs et à la structuration des
filières afin d'accéder d'accélérer
cette transformation
mais cette montée en gamme ne peut pas
uniquement reposer sur la
responsabilisation des professionnels et
l'accompagnement du gouvernement
les injonctions des citoyens doivent se
traduire dans leur acte d'achat
c'est tout le sens des galim dont
l'objectif est d'aboutir à une meilleure
rémunération des agriculteurs
nous devons sortir de la guerre des prix
bas il n'est pas possible de demander
toujours plus aux éleveurs sans leur en
donner les moyens
c'est tout le sens des travaux de serge
papin sur la contractualisation et la
pluri annualité c'est également le sens
de la proposition de loi et galim porté
par grégory basso moreau ce n'est qu'en
accompagnant nos éleveurs que ces
derniers pourront créer de la valeur et
faire face aux grands enjeux de société
cette transition comme toute transition
n'aura pas lieu sans un changement
profond des mentalités
c'est à dire tant que les éleveurs
seront forcés de produire toujours moins
cher le gouvernement est mobilisé aux
côtés des professionnels
à ce titre j'aimerais saisir
l'opportunité de répondre à certaines
critiques
certaines interpellations concernant
l'inscription de la pps sur la lutte
contre la maltraitance animale adopté à
l'assemblée nationale et je tiens ici
vous rassurer certes l'agenda du sénat
est particulièrement chargé et vous
savez mieux que moi mais je vous
confirme l'attention du gouvernement du
versed ppl inscrits à l'ordre du jour de
vos travaux avant la fin de l'année le
gouvernement est mobilisé et souhaite
préserver notre modèle d'élevage et
équilibré qui se distingue par des
exigences parmi les plus fortes au monde
mais là où certains mènent campagne de
dénonciation et de stigmatisation
généralisant trop souvent des cas isolés
nous revendiquons une politique de
mesures concrètes
en agissant sans trembler quand cela
s'impose mais sans jamais jeter
l'opprobre injustement sous tout un
secteur où toute une filière
gouvernement tiens ici à saluer le
travail mené par henri cabanel et
françoise férat sur l'accompagnement de
la détresse de cette profession
longtemps ignorée et messieurs les
sénateurs nous devons rejeter la
radicalité qui mettrait fin à l'élevage
français paraissait d'exigence je le
répète nous partageons cette volonté de
poursuivre l'amélioration de bonnes
pratiques
mais je vous invite à faire preuve de
raison de bons sens
cette question de l'avenir de l'élevage
suppose beaucoup d'ambition et de
pragmatisme mais surtout une confiance
en nos éleveurs
les éleveurs sont indiscutablement les
premiers a souhaité agir pour le bien
être des animaux et pour l'environnement
il travaille chaque jour pour nous
fournir la meilleure alimentation
possible et ce n'est pas en les
stigmatisant que nous aboutirons un
élevage plus durable mais leur donnant
les clés pour mener des transitions
ambitieuse il n'ya corps mettant la
question de la rémunération des éleveurs
au centre des discussions que nous
pourrons accélérer le changement durable
et que nous appelons de tous nos voeux
ont refusé cet état de fait c'est
condamner les éleveurs merci monsieur le
ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur henri cabanel
pour le groupe
rds eux
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la rapporteure madame la
commission la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques mes
chers collègues une proposition de loi
peut-elle en quelques bonnes intentions
changer le monde
c'est la question que je me pose souvent
lors d'examens de textes d'un jeu
sociétaux ce débat qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui en fait partie comment être
contre des objectifs d'élevage et
éthique rémunérateur socialement juste
et soucieux du bien-être animal
comment être contre l'interdiction de
l'élimination de pouce est malade et que
de cannes automne elles vivent je
remercie le groupe écologiste solidarité
et électeurs de porter en débat des
objectifs aussi noble cependant je
m'interroge sur l'opportunité d'un texte
de loi à ce sujet alors que le mal être
des agriculteurs n'a jamais était à son
paroxysme
deux agriculteurs se suicident chaque
jour ne les oublions pas si vous
l'évoquez dans l'exposé des motifs un
point d'amener levage intensif qui ne
respectent ni les agriculteurs ni les
animaux les mettant au même niveau
je souhaite ici poser un préambule la
nuance avec ma collègue françoise férat
nous sommes arrivés un vote unanime de
la commission des affaires économiques
pour le rapport que nous avons co signé
concernant la détresse des agriculteurs
c'est grâce à une posture de nuancer
loin des partis pris idéologiques notre
société confrontée aujourd'hui et plus
encore avec les réseaux sociaux qui
réduisent les débats à néant qui
sclérosent de la pensée qui la
congestion dans n'importe où contrat ne
plus comprendre les enjeux et les
impacts décisions parfois irrémédiables
l'agriculture focalise l'attention les
intentions les fausses informations
carano nourrissant en aménageant nos
territoires
elle est au coeur de nos vies et est le
clip souvent les idéologies via des
modèles opposé cette posture ne mènera à
rien si ce n'est à la cession des
extrêmes c'est pourquoi il faut après
appréhender de façon globale réunir
toutes les parties prenantes et agir
avec ensemble des postulats loin des
passions et des fantasmes
j'aime répéter que l'agriculture ce
n'est pas un enjeu
mais un faisceau d'enjeux
environnementaux économiques et sociaux
sociétaux
mais aussi le synthé public
d'indépendance alimentaire qu'il faut
traiter de façon transversale prévilégie
un axe plus tôt connantre déséquilibre
nos filières déjà bien fragilisée par
les crises sanitaires climatiques
économiques successives et par une perte
de compétitivité d'une sur transposition
des règles européennes
je m'inquiète réellement des effets des
lois qui ont des impacts sur nos seul
paysan français
j'estime que les gens jugent légitime
que vous posez doivent être examinés et
votés au niveau européen car limiter les
mesures aux éleveurs français qui vont
initier de ch et une concurrence
déloyale entre les filières des états
membres toute interdiction demande de
production va isoler un agriculteur
démarche européenne déjà très
concurrentiel et a fortiori au sein de
marché mondial libéral ou le prix le
plus bas s'oppose aux modes de
production durables
vous le savez je prends dans les
circuits courts le signe de qualité
mais alors que nos agriculteurs
travaillent en moyenne 55 55 heures par
semaine pour un salaire de 1000 36 euros
par mois soit 4 euros 60 et 10 de
l'heure je pense qu'il nous faut pour se
poser avant de trancher dans le vif
un très grand nombre c'est d'ailleurs
déjà tournés vers des pratiques
vertueuses
avez vous analysé les impacts de votre
texte sur la compétitivé filière avez
vous analysé l'impact financier des
mesures d'accompagnement avez-vous
réellement d'analyser l'impact sur le
bien-être animal car les consommateurs
qui mangent de la viande à bas prix se
tourneront vers des produits étrangers
alors aucune possibilité de connaître
les conditions de vie et d'abattage de
ces animaux résultats l'objectif premier
sera quasiment néant je suis sincèrement
persuadés que ce n'est pas une loi mais
bien une évolution des mentalités qui
changera le monde
associer le consommateur à l'acte
d'achat lui faire prendre conscience de
son choix n'est pas anodin qu'il peut
agir sur les modes de production
tout ceci est fondamental aucune loi ne
pourra remplacer ce libre arbitre il
faut donc accompagner le consommateur
l'étiquetage lui fournit les
informations dont il a besoin
les applications les qr codes les
nutrisse corps se développe
et la filière agroalimentaire répond à
la poussée sociétale à laquelle les
agriculteurs s'adapte déjà dans le
projet de loi climat prochainement
examinée dans cet hémicycle
des avancées sont déjà proposés dans le
titre 5 se nourrir et pour une
agriculture durable de qualité
ce véhicule législatif me semble le plus
légitime
nous pourrons l'amendé collectivement
c'est pourquoi notre groupe r d essieux
de sa majorité s'abstiendra sur cette
ppl la conscience et la raison ont aussi
force de loi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur fabien gay pour le groupe s'est
resserré
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la question du bien-être animal comporte
dimension scientifique éthiques
économiques culturelles sociales
religieuses et politiques et transcende
tous les courants de pensée et politique
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes
ils sont de plus en plus sensible et
nous ne pouvons nier les alertes lancées
sur la violence des conditions d'élevage
de transport et d'abattage dans certains
endroits
même si certains ne voudraient pas les
voir quand d'autres voudraient les
cacher la maltraitance dans certains
abattoirs l'élevage en batterie
le broyage du poussin interroge notre
braudel agro industriel mais aussi plus
largement notre modèle de société
car ce que nous inflige aux animaux est
un miroir somme sur lequel il ne fait
pas bon de se pencher la pression
productiviste et les inégalités
s'intensifie pour les humains comme pour
les animaux sont joints à la violence
subie par les animaux d'élevage intensif
mais songeons aussi à la violence subie
par le personnel des abattoirs à celle
des licenciements massifs par des
groupes peu scrupuleux lancer dans la
course au profit et je pourrais
continuer ainsi une longue litanie
accepté la possibilité de maltraiter
quel que soit l'être maltraités c'est
ouvrir une brèche qui est voué à se
creuser
c'est créer un précédent dans la
violence et l'aliénation c'est vouloir
détruire l'altérité
l'alimentation est à la fois une
nécessité vitale
un plaisir et un moment de convivialité
avec nos proches mais à l'heure de la
crise environnementale et de
l'industrialisation l'élevage nous
n'avons d'autre choix que d'intégrer
aussi sa dimension éthique repenser le
rapport de l'humain à la nature au monde
animal est une nécessité
toutefois nous pensons qu'il faut sortir
d'une vision binaire pour ou contre
l'élevage ou la viande pour poser la
question du mot
d'élevage et d'agriculture que nous
voulons l'émergence de la question du
bien-être animal frapper un secteur déjà
fragile il fragilisé pardonnez-moi par
les crises sanitaires économiques de ces
dernières décennies mais défendre
l'élevage se reconnaître les dérives
entraînée par le modèle hyper
productiviste soit 80% l'élevage en
france qui nuit à l'ensemble des
éleveurs en 2019 le conseil économique
social et environnemental alertés sur
ces transformations et la baisse de
rémunération qui l'accompagné ainsi en
30 ans le nombre d'éleveurs a chuté de
57% pour les porcs et volailles de 70%
pour les vaches laitières
cet effondrement n'a pas empêché les
cheptels d'augmenter ni les animaux
d'être abattu en masse c'est
l'agriculture paysanne qui est la
première victime au profit de fer movil
vaches france nature environnement
pointe la concentration croissante qui
entraîne des risques sanitaires et un
impact environnemental et la
multiplication des accords de
libre-échange pression supplémentaire
pour nos agriculteurs et sur nos
agriculteurs exacerbera encore ce
phénomène
c'est dans ce cadre qu'il faut
appréhender la ppl du groupe écologiste
qui vise à trouver un équilibre entre un
impératif des éleveurs sans les
stigmatiser et la recherche de
meilleures conditions d'élevage
la plupart des réglementations et cahier
des charges national européenne visant à
protéger les animaux sont basés sur les
cinq liberté du rapport bramble qui date
déjà de 1965 il s'agissait il s'agit
toujours d'assurer l'absence de faim et
de soif d'un confort de douleurs de
blessures et de maladies de peur et de
détresse et enfin de garantir un espace
suffisant et adapté et la compagnie
d'autres congénères mais elles ne sont
pas contraignantes et les moyens
manquent pour assurer les contrôles et
pour que nos éleveurs puissent réaliser
cette transition
c'est tout l'intérêt de l'article 4 qui
propose un fonds dédié pour cette
transition inscrire dans une vie
l'ong il faut aller plus loin et passer
d'un élevage intensif industriels et
destructeur à un élevage respectueux de
l'environnement de l'humain et de la
planète
c'est pourquoi nous voterons cette
proposition de loi et que nous
interviendrons pour défendre un certain
nombre d'amendements qui ont été
déposées je vous remercie chers
collègues
merci chers collègues la parole et mrm
françoise férat pour le groupe union
centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission vadam moulin à porter mes
chers collègues le développement de
nombreuses associations de défense des
animaux et les actions coup de poing
qu'elles peuvent mener ces dernières
années sont des manifestations de
l'importance que revêt le bien-être des
animaux dans l'opinion publique
nous avons vu les images choquantes de
certains abattoirs diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux et nous n'y sommes pas
insensibles
mais permettez moi également de penser
aux hommes qui travaillent le constat
posé par cette proposition de loi met en
lumière de véritables enjeux sociétaux
que nous ne devons pas négliger
rappelons que les éleveurs dans leur
très grande majorité réprouve ces
traitements ignoble il respecte au
quotidien le bien être de leurs animaux
que les exploitations soient petites ou
grandes
il applique scrupuleusement les normes
européennes et nationales pour assurer
de bonnes conditions à leurs bêtes
ils ont investi des centaines de
millions d'euros pour adapter leurs
étables leur porcherie jusqu'à la
prochaine norme
soyons clair s'ils sont avérés les
manquements bien-être animal doivent
être sanctionnés des intentions de ce
texte sont louables et l'union centriste
partage la volonté d'améliorer les
conditions de travail des éleveurs
evans aide les animaux de ferme
malheureusement les solutions avancées
dans cette proposition de loi ne
répondent pas aux problématiques
profonde de la filière ce texte risque
de mettre un peu plus à genoux
financièrement nos producteurs qui
respecte les règles
le dispositif proposé n'est pas
applicable
grenon article 1er lorsqu'on s'intéresse
à sa mise en oeuvre qu'on constate
qu'ils posent plus de problèmes qu'il
n'en résout
d'un point de vue technique de toutes
les nerfs n'est pas faisable
l'accès au foncier sera un facteur
limitant pour beaucoup d'éleveurs
ces mesures vont fragiliser les filières
et les agriculteurs qui ne parviendront
pas à réaliser les investissements
nécessaires cesseront leur activité sans
repreneur
il ne faut pas que la généralisation du
plein air face le nouveau standard au
détriment de la rémunération aux
producteurs sans consentement du
consommateur à payer le coût du
changement de pratique cette mesure
encouragera les importations et plein
air ne signifie pas toujours bien être
lorsque les conditions du milieu
pourtant ces sols pente et s'est ouvert
climatiques neige forte chaleur ne sont
pas adaptés à la sortie des animaux
depuis le 6 novembre dont les vaches de
plein air systématique
nous faciliterons la diffusion d'épinés
vie animale
quelles dispositions seront prises pour
contrer la propagation évalue l
éventuelle de la peste porcine
comment empêcher des contacts avec la
faune sauvage vecteur de grippe aviaire
idem pour les modifications proposées
pour les transports d'animaux à
l'article 2 si nous limitons à 4h les
transports dans l'hexagone comment
s'assurer que les camions ne feront pas
de détour par l'étranger quelle sera la
facture carbone de test
20 sur le papier tout est très simple
mais sur le terrain ses solutions ne
sont pas fonctionnels l'enjeu
prioritaire pour assurer le temps de
transport le plus réduit possible pour
les animaux et bien de renforcer un
maillage d'abattoirs de proximité viable
économiquement est sanitairement fiable
ce dispositif de plus ce n'est pas
viable financièrement en filière porcine
la construction de bâtiments offrant un
accès au plein air cours est différent
d'élevage en kleinert coûterait 13
milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble du
cheptel le budget nécessaire pour
accompagner la transition par rapport
aux moyens disponibles rend ces mesures
irréaliste
à titre de comparaison le plan de
relance prévoit une enveloppe de 100
millions d'euros pour l'ensemble de la
mesure biosécurité et bien-être animal
vous l'avez compris tout cela est bien
insuffisant pour une telle position
la france devrait elle créer une
nouvelle taxe et pénaliser la
compétitivité de la filière française
ce dispositif n'est pas viable non plus
pour les éleveurs n'oublions pas en
effet que ces restructurations un prix
pour les producteurs car tous ne seront
pas éligibles aux aides du fonds de
soutien pour eux ce serait la double
peine
s'endetter pour financer les
investissements qui ne sortiront pas à
court terme et augmenter le prix de
leurs produits
déjà un peu compétitifs sur le marché
international
sachant qu'un français sur fait saute
des repas pour des raisons financières
vous comprendrez aisément que le
consommateur moyen pour ericsson
accentuer son choix ou du port espagnol
par exemple deux fois moins cher que le
port français exemple d'efforts
financiers déjà consentis par les
éleveurs
arrêté le voyage des pousse à des
solutions alternatives sont actuellement
engagés par les professionnels recherche
de nouveaux marchés en france et à
l'export permettant l'exportation des
poussins actuellement éliminé par
exemple les coquelets ou la recherche
d'une solution permettant le sexage non
avant l'éclosion des poussins la france
a présenté un travail commun avec
l'allemagne pour parvenir à une solution
viable pour la filière fin 2021 date à
laquelle a été annoncé l'interdiction de
cette pratique
enfin chers collègues n'oublions pas les
efforts déjà consentis en matière
environnementale et sociétale par
l'agriculture en général et la filière
de l'élevage en particulier trop souvent
oubliée au profit d'un agri bachy
grandissant et agressif
je témoigne ici au nom du groupe union
centriste que la ferme france est la
meilleure du monde
contraindre une fois de plus l'élevage
français aggravera la situation de
détresse devant laquelle certains sont
confrontés l'élevage français souffrent
et je rappellerai peut-être cela dit
notre collègue henri cabanel tout à
l'heure des chiffres qu'il faut qu'ils
font mal
travaillons de concert avec les éleveurs
pour leur assurer un revenu décent
travaillons pour convaincre nos
compatriotes qu une viande de qualité
respectant le bien-être animal requiert
un prix d'achat lui aussi descend en
votant contre ce texte le groupe uc en
temps réaffirmé l'excellence de la
filière française il se montrer
solidaires des éleveurs
grand oublié de la proposition de loi
mais pourtant tellement attentif aux
conditions de vie de leurs animaux
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur franck montaugé
pour le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis le
néolithique qui voit la sédentarisation
se développe et l'apparition de
l'élevage dans de nombreuses régions du
monde
l'homme a évolué dans une relation à la
fois constructives et problématique avec
l'animal que cet animal soit mythique
sauvage ou élevé à des fins nourricière
ou d'auxiliaires de travail porté par
par la pensée de l'antiquité à nos jours
la nature de cette relation a été
interrogé dans les cadres de la religion
de l'éthique et de la morale de
l'économie et du droit en général de la
nature et des droits particuliers que
nous lui avons progressivement reconnus
je ne rappellerai pas les grandes étapes
de ce cheminement intellectuel mais on
sait qu'il était déjà présent dans
l'antiquité que d'aucuns considèrent
chimérique mans peut-être comme l'âge
d'or de la relation entre l'homme et
l'animal de ce long cheminement qui a
connu des infections importante au xviie
siècle en angleterre et en france au
moment des lumières avec condillac et
sont prémonitoires traiter les animaux
deux concepts différents émerger celui
du droit de l'animal est celui du
bien-être animal
je remercie nos collègues du groupe
écologiste qui souhaite avec ce texte
faire avancer concrètement le bien-être
animal
la loi de 2015 je tiens à le rappeler
reconnaissait à l'animal la qualité
d'êtres vivants doux et de sensibilité
ouvrant parle parle à la voie d'un
fondement juridique de la notion de
bien-être animal
je laisse de côté la question du droit
de l'animal pour vous dire que nous
souscrivons aux exigences et critères du
bien-être animal qu'a rappelé il ya
quelques instants fabien gay mais y
souscrire ne laisse pas entendre que
rien aujourd'hui n'est fait en ce sens
ou que les éleveurs et industriels
français ne s'en soucie pas moi comme
beaucoup ici j'ai pu au sein de ma
famille
comprendre ce que peut être la relation
affective
je pèse le monde donne éleveurs
responsables à ses bêtes et je peux vous
dire que les jours où on voit partir ses
bêtes à l'abattoir ou qu'on les amène
soi-même à l'abattoir
ces jours-là son du jour moralement
difficile très difficile
les abattoirs parlons-en ceux qui les
gèrent et même peut-être plus encore
quand ce sont des industriels
responsables
il y en a beaucoup s'ils le sont
peut-être pas tous savent qu'il faut
être irréprochable sur les règles à
respecter pour les animaux ils sont
attendus là dessus par une grande partie
de la société et ils savent les études
le montrent le sujet et sociétal il
prend de plus en plus d'importance dans
les consciences des citoyens et des
consommateurs
en conséquence de quoi c'est l'image ou
la marque et le chiffre d'affaires qui
sont aussi affectés je le dis au
gouvernement les mesures prévues dans la
loi et galine de 2018 nous interroge sur
leur efficacité et même leur effectivité
dans le cadre juridique actuel il faut
se donner les moyens de contrôler et de
sanctionner comme il se doit les fautifs
c'est votre rôle est votre
responsabilité monsieur le ministre
de la même manière nous nous
interrogeons sur les suites données aux
mesures pour la protection et
l'amélioration du bien-être animal
proposé aux interprofessions par le
gouvernement en janvier 2005
quel bilan monsieur le ministre alors
j'avais écrit monsieur le ministre eric
hull tueur de l'alimentation monsieur le
ministre tire t'il de ce plan en six
objectifs que je vais rappeler aller
vers la fin des pratiques douloureuses
années le vagin renforcer la
sensibilisation et la formation
bien-être animal améliorer la qualité de
vie des animaux d'élevage et améliorer
les conditions de transport des animaux
améliorer l'information des
consommateurs et responsabiliser les
propriétaires d'animaux de compagnie où
en êtes vous est il toujours d'actualité
c'est le flou complet à partir de là que
proposons nous nous voulons inséré un
article additionnel quand je dis nous
c'est le groupe socialiste avant
l'article premier de ce texte
cet article additionnel demande au
gouvernement de remettre au parlement un
bis
un état des lieux exhaustif de
l'ensemble des démarches engagées en
faveur du bien-être animal en france et
de leur efficacité
ce bilan informera sur les actions mises
en oeuvre dans le monde de l'élevage
mais aussi celle impulsée ou porté par
la société civile ou les entreprises
ce panneau rhône-alpes panorama précis
permettra aux pouvoirs publics mais
également à l'ensemble des acteurs
mobilisés sur cette question de savoir
réellement où la france se situe en
matière de bien-être animal et en
conséquence les mesures proportionnées à
mettre en oeuvre pour accompagner et
accélérer si nécessaire à ce mouvement
pour avoir un débat apaisé sur la
question du bien-être animal
nous devons à savoir précisément d'où
nous partons réellement est
objectivement pour mettre en oeuvre des
actions ou des politiques ciblées et
efficaces
en fait nous tenons à rappeler notre
attachement à l'élevage à ce qu'il
représente pour nos territoires je viens
moi-même d'un territoire le gers de
polyculture élevage qui souffrent et qui
souffre beaucoup et aux éleveurs dont je
ne connais guère de métier plus
difficile 24 heures sur 24 tous les
jours de l'année pour en revenus
misérable de plus en plus misérables
quels seront les impacts de la pac dès
2022 ou 2023 sur l'élevage en france et
galine 2 est aussi attendu vous le savez
le plus vite sera le mieux
même si en réalité plus grandement denis
croit alors parce qu'ils sont en
première ligne de la souffrance nous
vous proposerons à l'article 4 que les
aides prévues visite également la mettre
en oeuvre des mesures de soutien et
d'accompagnement psychologique pour les
agriculteurs
sans oublier les opérateurs de
l'abattage ceci afin de leur apporter
une écoute et de leur proposer des
mesures améliorant leur beignets leur
bien-être au travail et leur bien-être
tout court dom une femme de travailleurs
digne
de respect et de considération je vous
remercie
merci monsieur montaugé notre volonté
monsieur france mais non ville pour le
groupe les indépendances
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la rapporteure madame la
présidente de la commission mes chers
collègues je tiens tout d'abord à saluer
le travail mené par notre collègue
esther benbassa en lien avec madame la
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques
marie christine chauvin elles ont mené
un travail complet en consultant les
acteurs des filières
cette proposition de loi nous permet
d'ouvrir un débat important en discutant
d'options concrètes et pas seulement
d'idées abstraites et je le dis au nom
des de mon groupe les indépendants nous
partageons les préoccupations de notre
collègue pour valoriser le travail des
éleveurs et améliorer le bien-être
animal
mais vous ne vous en doutez je ne
partage pas et nous ne partageons pas
pour autant les mesures proposées avant
d'exposer les raisons de notre désaccord
sur ce texte je tiens à saluer les
efforts continus qui ont été fournis par
nos agriculteurs pour adapter leurs
méthodes de travail aux nouvelles
préoccupations et attentes sociétales et
environnementales
toutes ces évolutions vont dans le bon
sens d'ailleurs la france s'inscrit dans
une dynamique européenne
partout sur le continent nos
agriculteurs s'adapte pour mieux prendre
en compte les attentes des consommateurs
en matière de sécurité alimentaire et de
poteaux protection de l'environnement et
du bien-être animal
l'agriculture française il faut le dire
et le marteler est une des plus durable
au monde survient des aspects nous
sommes en avance et nous pouvons en être
fiers
mais vous aurions tort de réfléchir dans
un cadre franco français car notre
agriculture doit aussi veiller à rester
compétitives en évitant de faire émerger
des distorsions de concurrence entre
pays européens notamment
c'est en conquérant des marchés des
marchés à l'international et en
réalisant des investissements productifs
que notre agriculture pourra conserver
son excellence
sa robustesse et contribuer pleinement à
la sega souveraineté est allé sécurité
alimentaire de la france si nous
décidons de faire peser de nouvelles
contraintes sur nos agriculteurs de
façon franco-français cela altérera
irrémédiablement la compétitivité de
notre agriculture et risquera de laisser
davantage encore la place à des produits
importés qui ne respectent pas toujours
nos valeurs alors soyons cohérents
n'importons pas déjà ce tout seul parce
que nous ne nous nous autorisons pas à
produire il faut donc travailler au
niveau européen pour avancer de façon
collective et concertée mais aussi au
sein des accords internationaux
le sénat travaille depuis longtemps pour
soutenir les évolutions de notre
agriculture en lien avec les
préoccupations de nos concitoyens ce fut
le cas au sein de la durant la l'examen
de la loi et galim lors du dernier
budget également nous étions nombreux à
soutenir la madone la modernisation des
abattoirs et des élevages dans le cadre
du plan de relance cela donc nous montre
que nous pouvons améliorer notre
performance économique en y intégrant le
bien-être animal
en conclusion je rappellerai que nous
devons aussi nous préoccuper du
bien-être des éleveurs qui aiment leurs
animaux leur métier est difficile et
exigeant il leur faut beaucoup de
passion pour l'exercer qu'il soit donc
aujourd'hui remercier et honorer dans
cet hémicycle alors à l'article 4 un
amendement numéro 2
monsieur montaugé le présente
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues cet amendement du groupe
socialiste s'est inscrit en réalité dans
les dents les travaux beaucoup plus
large menée par henri cabanel et
françoise férat que que je salue travaux
qu'il faut me désormais référencée c'est
une excellente chose parce qu'il ya
grand besoin
si je devais rajouter un point
particulier c'est celui des opérateurs
d'abattoirs qui sommes qui travaillent
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles et un dépanneur la question
du bien-être animal et qui travaillent
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles qui sont confrontés à la mort
en permanence qu'il a donnée qui la
donnent ça fait partie de leur métier
alors je vais pas je veux pas revenir à
des références littéraires et
philosophiques à nouveau mais bon ça
sans citer personne voilà ces univers en
quelque chose en tout cas certains le
considèrent ont quelque chose à voir
avec l'univers concentrationnaire ça
naît ça n'est pas rien et je pèse mes
mots en disant ça il ya des gens voilà
de très haut niveau qui se sont exprimé
là-dessus et et moment comme beaucoup
d'entre nous ici si ce n'est la plupart
d'entre nous j'ai visité des abattoirs
on est et on se rend compte de ce que ça
de ce que ça représente pour moi je
voudrais qu'ils et voilà une aide ou d
accompagnement particulier pour ces pour
ses opérateurs en même temps que pour
les éleveurs qui sommes confrontés eux
aussi à des à des conditions est
extrêmement difficile par rapport à
l'heure à leur métier merci monsieur
montage et madame le rapporteur avis de
la commission
merci madame la présidente
comme pour les autres amendements est
toujours par souci de cohérence je suis
désolé la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
compte tenu du sort qu'elle propose de
donner au final la proposition de loi
comme l'expliquent l'exposer comme
explicite pardon à l'exposé des motifs
c'est un amendement d'appel qui établit
un lien très juste entre le bien être
animal
le billet
faut des éleveurs la pensée aux
professionnels et des abattoirs en outre
ces mesures peuvent également être mise
en place dès aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement et je voulais ce monsieur
le ministre
répondre et de notre côté delà du côté
de la commission c'est un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs les sénateurs
cet amendement rejoint pleinement les
préoccupations du gouvernement
la prévention du mal être et du risque
6/10 suicidaire est un enjeu majeur des
politiques publiques de santé au travail
s'appuyant d'une part sur le rapport du
député damaisin et sur les 63
recommandations formulées par la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat est rapportée par les sénateurs
ferrat et cabanel un plan d'action
portant sur les moyens mis en oeuvre par
l'état en matière de prévention et
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs en
situation de détresse sera présenté par
le ministère de l'agriculture dans les
prochaines semaines
le plan de relance de modernisation des
abattoirs constitue également une
formidable opportunité pour que les
projets d'investissement permettent une
réelle amélioration des conditions de
travail et de la protection animale les
deux ambition étant intimement liées le
gouvernement étant défavorables article
4 il ne peut donner un avis favorable à
cet amendement
même s'il rejoint totalement vos
préoccupations merci monsieur le
ministre
s'il n'ya pas d'explications de vote je
vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 2 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables de la commission et du
gouvernement
manquer pour qui contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté alors mes chers
collègues je vous rappelle que si cet
article n'était pas adoptée il n'y
aurait plus lieu de voter sur l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi dans la mesure
où les quatre articles qui la composent
aurait été supprimé il n'y aurait donc
pas d'explications de vote sur
l'ensemble est donc quelqu'un
demande-t-il la parole pour expliquer
son vote
monsieur boulou monsieur boulou pour
commencer
un peu oui on peut faire ça le groupe
l'est républicain du sénat suivra l'avis
de madame la rapporteure cela pour
plusieurs raisons
les éleveurs français sont les premiers
à être soucieux du bien être de leurs
animaux et les méfaits de certains ne
doivent pas jeter l'opprobre sur toute
une profession
toutes les filières ont engagé des
actions en faveur de l'amélioration des
conditions d'élevage ces dernières
années par exemple la mise en place par
inaporc du cycle de base du port
français intégrant des critères de
bien-être animal minimum lumière
matériaux manipulable abreuvement ces
évolutions sont également accompagnés
par les consommateurs cela est
particulièrement visible pour les une
baisse significative des capacités de
production des élevages en cage a été
constaté au profit des élevages
alternatif qui représentent désormais
sas 53% d'être cool qu'on 2 contre 19%
en 2008
toutes ces avancées ne sont pas faites
sans recourir à la loi
et comme l'a expliqué madame la
rapporteure la meilleure échelle pour
prendre des décisions visant à encadrer
certaines pratiques d'élevage de
transport et d'abattage comme le propose
le texte
l échelle européenne qui travaille déjà
sur ces sujets enfin si nous partageons
par certains aspects la police la folie
la part dont la philosophie de ce texte
nous sommes aussi soucieux du bien-être
des agriculteurs qui sont actuellement
soumis à d'importantes difficultés
économiques et un à guy bashing
permanent est insupportable la grande
majorité du groupe votera contre
certains d'entre nous obtiendrons merci
et mathieu lou
madame benbassa pour explication
d'autres qui prend la parole pour une
explication de vote madame benbassa et
monsieur seulement ensuite monsieur
vantard merci madame la présidente je
constate avec disons je regrette que
notre assemblée soit si loin des
demandes de la population des demandes
des jeunes et des demandes des
consommateurs et de l'avenir qui
prochainement sera favorable à la date à
la dope à l'adoption de ces quatre
articles
ce test est peut-être un peu pionnier
mais en même temps je dirais que par
rapport à l'allemagne
nous sommes en retard et par rapport à
d'autres pays nous n'avons pas nous
enorgueillir
dans ce texte nous avons voulu c'est un
travail d'équipé
je remercie mes collègues joël labbé et
daniel salmon
nous allons travailler ensemble avec les
associations les personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces sujets avec des
syndicats d'agriculteurs
nous avons fait un travail qui est à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans la
société
comment pourrons nous être si loin de la
réalité des exigences on est on dirait
connaît dans un conservatisme qui nous
empêche de penser ces questions qui sont
des questions inéluctable dans l'avenir
alors avons nous en refusant ce test
avez vous eu peur du débat c'est une
question à poser
parce que nous sommes là dans cette
assemblée pas pour eux je te les textes
mais pour discuter avancer préparer
l'avenir
alors vraiment je crois que nous ne sont
pas aujourd'hui à ce point qui
devrait nous caractérise et une
assemblée a besoin d'ouvrir la voie à
l'avenir et nous sommes bien loin de
ceux là enfermés dans notre
conservatisme et yann c'est pas la
question des agriculteurs puisque nous
avons conçu ce texte
dans ce trio bien être animal bien-être
des agriculteurs bien-être des
consommateurs
c'est vraiment triste de se dire une
fois de plus que nous sommes en retard
et la parole est à mme est ce seulement
merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues c'est vrai que c'est
un grand regret parce que je pense que
c'est une occasion manquée de faire
évoluer cet élevage industriel agro
industriel vers un système plus
respectueux à la fois des agriculteurs
mais également du bien-être animal
nous avons essayé avec mes collègues de
faire une loi équilibré une loi nuance
est bien loin de ce que vous appelez la
grille bashing nous ne sommes pas du
tout dans la grille bashing nous fait
c'est vous qui parfois fait des
amalgames et plutôt que de débattre
c'est facile de nous renvoyer dans les
cordes la grille bashing ce n'est pas du
tout le cas de cette loi nous donnions
du temps jusqu'en 2040
il me semble qu'en 19 ans on peut faire
évoluer un modèle en refusant de faire
évoluer ce modèle au lieu de sauver
l'élevage
vous êtes en train de condamner toute
une partie de l'élevage car cet élevage
ne pourra pas se défendre face à de la
viande de synthèse de la viande de
laboratoire puisque nous nous
rapprochons de cette on parle de qualité
de viande
on en a parlé plusieurs fois quelle
qualité de la viande de ces élevages
industriels du poulet de six semaines du
poulet avec de la viande qui s'effiloche
de la viande spaghetti comme on peut
trouver encore parce qu'on peut encore
faire mieux on peut enlever au pire en
se comparant aux etats unis puisque des
fois on est dans le monde
dix ans le moins disant c'est du poulet
encore une semaine de moins avec de la
viande qui n'a aucune valeur gustative
ce sont des muscles qui ne fonctionne
pas et dans les si on veut continuer
dans le muscle qui ne fonctionne pas on
peut faire encore beaucoup mieux
c'est-à-dire élevé des cellules de
muscle tout simplement en hors sol en
laboratoire si on ne voulut pas eh bien
c'est la mort de l'élevage en france
bientôt vous avez la parole
oui merci merci madame la présidente je
profite quand même un petit peu de ceux
de ce temps de parole moi je suis aussi
assez étonné parce que ce que j'ai pu
entendre que j'ai entendu un grigri
bashing radicalisme stigmatisant
opprobre amalgame est en fait je me
demande si vous avez juste lu ce texte
est et si vous avez vous est allé
jusqu'au bout parce qu'il me semble
qu'on est totalement très loin de ça je
pense qu'on ait beaucoup ici à vivent
dans des territoires où l'élevage est
présent ou l'élevage existe et à
constater tous les jours que cet élevage
que ce petit élevage de plein air eh
bien il disparaît qu'on a des éleveurs
qui sont en grande difficulté et vous
l'avez d'ailleurs tout se dit et les
mesures qu'on a ici
favoriser l'élevage de plein air
interdire le broyage limiter les
transports à 8 heures c'est à dire
favoriser plutôt justement la
consommation locale
un fonds de soutien justement pour les
paysans monsieur du plomb nous a
expliqué qu'il était éleveur et donc il
pouvait il pouvait en parler j'ai
l'impression que tout ce qui est là il
le fait c'est exactement à ce type
d'élevage qu'on s'adresse est exactement
justement vers ça qu'on veut aller et
c'est exactement ce type d'élevage que
l'on veut que l'on souhaite que l'on
souhaite soutenir et à linverse bien sûr
ne pas favoriser l'élevage industriel
qui n'est non seulement pas créateur
d'emplois qui n'a pas d'impact locales
et au contraire revenir sur une
production sur une production locale
avec des paysans qui sont fiers de ce
qu'ils réalisent et on le voit tous les
jours dans les marchés partout dans nos
communes des consommateurs qui sont
contents heureux de discuter avec leurs
éleveurs et 2 et 2 et de manger des
viandes de qualité et d'aller vers vers
du bio donc c'est bien le sens de ce
texte et je ne comprends pas que vous ne
devriez pas compris parce que c'est pas
si on partage le constat j'ai été a pas
très longtemps j'ai entendu parler de de
la h1n1 de la grippe porcine
j'ai été ya pas très longtemps justement
mais avec des petits éleveurs en élevage
de plein air qu'est ce qu'ils nous
disaient toutes les mesures actuelles
qui sont prises sont contre ce qu ont
les plus grandes difficultés toutes les
mesures sanitaires sont envers
l'agriculture industrielle alors que on
sait justement que c'est ce type
d'élevage ce type d'élevage extérieur
qui est le plus résilient par rapport à
ces maladies puisqu'on sait que la
propagation de ces maladies elle est dû
à quoi
justement aux distances de transport et
qu'on a bien plus intérêts
défend cet élevage local de proximité et
c'est ce que tout le monde attend et
c'est ce qu'on a voulu faire ici et je
regrette que l'on n'ait eu un vote
totalement dogmatique ce soir merci
monsieur vente à la parole est à mme et
ses voisins merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je crois qu'il faut redire encore une
fois que madame benbassa monsieur
gonfaron particulier que si nous ne
venons pas cette proposition de loi
ça n'est pas parce que nous ne
partageons pas ses objectifs un élevage
plus respectueux des animaux et qui
enfin garantissent d'être des revenus
décents à nos agriculteurs nous
partageons tous cet objectif et ses
valeurs simplement je crois qu'il a été
amplement démontré que la ppl n'est pas
opérationnel tout simplement parce que
la question est multidimensionnelle je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure à les complexes
si on s'abstrait de l'échelon européen
et international
si on ne prend pas en compte la réalité
quel comportement des consommateurs si
on prend par l iran qu on en compte la
réalité de la longue évolution qui va
être nécessaire pour modifier les
comportements alimentaires à travers une
éducation qui s'y attaquent pour une
bonne foi et bien on ne fera rien
d'utile
il est nécessaire que ce soit un projet
porté par un gouvernement avec une
grande ambition dans une grande durée
avec des lois-cadres certainement mais
c'est pas en quatre articles de ppl
qu'on peut régler cette question nous
sommes nous ne sommes pas des gens
dogmatique nous sommes des gens
pragmatiques et nous constatons que
cette ppl ne fonctionne pas c'est tout
sinon pour le reste je vous donne très
volontiers acte que cet objectif doit
être poursuivi avec acharnement et
détermination
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues souvent on
fait reproche à mes collègues
écologistes d'être trop radicales ou
d'être dans une écologie punitive
c'est beaucoup de mots qu'on entend
comme ça je ne partage pas ça mais pour
le coup on avait une proposition de loi
est d'ailleurs l'article
j'entends ce que me disent yeux notre
collègue bazin s'inscrire dans le temps
long parce que moi je viens d'un camp
qui pensent que cette transition
on ne l'a réussira pas contre ou sans
les agriculteurs mais avec eux d'accord
et qu'on leur a imposé un modèle hyper
productiviste qui fait ce que vous avez
dit c'est-à-dire qui aujourd'hui n'ont
leur grande garantie pas d'eau un revenu
décent
donc ça c'est un problème mais y compris
dans l'article 1 de la proposition de
loi
il propose d'interdire l'élevage
intensif non pas demain matin à
l'horizon 2040 2040 donc dites moi mais
c'est quoi la bonne perspective pour
vous dix neuf ans ça vous paraît pas
s'est donc dit noah dit lou vous voulez
la deuxième chose je reviens sur
l'article 4 on propose d'accompagner les
agriculteurs avec un fonds dédié pour le
coup ça c'est ni radicales ni punitif
c'est pas contre ou sans les
agriculteurs mais c'est bien avec eux
parce qu'on partage qu'on leur a imposé
un modèle productiviste ya cinquante ans
et que si on veut aller vers un produit
un modèle ce qu'on appelle paysans plus
respectueux éthique peu importe il va
fort les accompagner dans cette
transition et je vous ai senti un peu
parfois mal à l'aise et ça va pour le
coup jusqu'au bout c'est que les
amendements qui étaient proposés vous en
partager l'objectif mais vous retrouver
pour le coc a voté contre et là on a un
problème je le dis
j'ai dit ce matin la commission de texte
proposition de loi des groupes
minoritaires et d'opposition et là on un
véritable problème
et pour finir moi je pense que c'est un
débat qui commence qui a déjà commencé
en société mais qu'ici c'est la première
étape et on va continuer parce que plus
largement que ça c'est le rapport à la
nature
le rapport aux autres la question de
l'animal c'est pas que l'alimentation
c'est aussi par exemple aujourd'hui
notre rapport avec les animaux dans les
cirques dans les parcs d'attraction est
ce qu'un animal peut être un objet ou
pas c'est notre rapport avec les animaux
de compagnie voilà et je vous dis c'est
un débat plus large de société et dans
lequel est inclus l'élevage éthiques
mais deux coups du court on sera amené à
se prononcer plusieurs fois sur ces
questions et sur le ministre sans
polémique
on attend que vous inscriviez la
proposition de loi du groupe ar marc'h
d'envoi de niche
ici au sénat ou par le gouvernement pour
remercier en tout cas notre rôle était
même seul le groupe a reçu du plomb
d'abord pas excusez moi même c'est
d'abord monsieur du plan merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre à
l'interpellation mais qui m'a été faite
mais parce que tout simplement l'article
1 de la loi n'est pas ne peut pas se
mettre en place
tout simplement demain vous sortez tous
les ports de france en plein air on a
déjà dit parce que c'est écrit dans le
rapport
il faut grosso modo la surface d'un seul
département d'un seul département et je
voudrais quand même pour tous ceux qui
ne connaissent pas apporté quand même
quelques éléments les élevages de porcs
en plein air c'est le labourage complet
de la parcelle
c'est l'érosion à chaque orage c'est la
disparition totale de la surface de
terre qui peut y aura sur cet
emplacement à c'est pas dogmatique
c'est la réalité on ne peut pas mettre
tous les atouts les ports en plein air
alors si on va jusqu'au bout
si on les oblige il y aura plus
d'élevage de porcs en france très peu
comme l'a dit arnaud bazin juste pour
une minorité de consommateurs qui prend
se payer ce luxe là et à côté de ça nous
ne mangerons que du porc élevé ailleurs
dans des méthodes qui sont même pires
que celles qu'on a mis en place après ça
veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas des
évolutions à mener après ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya pas d évolution emmené
enfin fabien en seine saint denis je
veux bien que tu m'expliques comment que
ça se passe et enfin un moment il faut
quand même rester raisonnable
faut quand même rester raisonnable mais
il ya une autre
un autre élément tu prends sur mon
élevage quand je dis que je fais pâturer
mes animaux sur mes vaches laitières je
fais de l'eau à l'eau début de lactation
1 lot fin de lactation 50 vaches sur
d'or 25 reste dedans mais à chaque fois
elles sont remplacées par une autre qui
va sortir
si on met une règle dogmatique sur le
principe de sortir tous les animaux ben
j'en ai 25 qui reste dans 50 qui sortent
c'est ouais c'est bien sûr six escales
dans la loi battant tu l'as lu la loi
c'est exactement ce qu'a dans la loi
2026 tous les bâtiments doivent
permettre 2026 tous les bâtiments
doivent permettre de pouvoir sortir les
animaux 2040 tous les animaux doivent
être en plein air c'est pas moi qui les
écrit c'est vous donc il faut quand même
pas faire dire ce que vous avez écrit lé
inverse de ce qui est écrit la fin de
l'état l'ademe sollogoub oui merci à la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
moi je suis lu dans un département où
les éleveurs tentent de survivre en
exportant les broutards en italie alors
si demain je rentre dans la nièvre à
leur disant qu'ils peuvent pas partir en
italie je pense que je vais leur
définitivement leur casser le moral
deuxième chose
je rejoins totalement ce qu'a dit
monsieur bazin ce texte il est
totalement lacunaire parce que encore
parole d'éleveurs y en a qui me disent
j'ai tellement mal quand je vois les
l'énergie que je mets à élever mes bêtes
faut qu'elles soient dans de bonnes
conditions et qu'elle parte à l'abattoir
et qu'elles soient abattus sans
étourdissement
on ne peut pas parler de bien être
animal sans aborder ce problème madame
benbassa je suis désolé vous nous dit
qu'on est pas courageux mais j'ai trouvé
qu'il manquait un gros gros morceau dans
ce texte c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'on peut pas parler de bien-être
animal sans aborder cette question de
l'abattage sans étourdissement c'est
vraiment énorme
je remercie merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques mots pour dire que voilà à
l'ère de l'anthropocène parce que on est
dans ceux d'un ce moment là de
l'histoire de notre humanité
toutes les filières économiques
l'ensemble des populations sur
l'ensemble de la terre 1 sont contraints
d'évoluer
voilà je crois que je crois qu'il faut
partir vraiment de ça et le texte qui
nous a été proposé à cet égard alors
fait des propositions mettez des
orientations sur la table qu'on a
discuté on n'est pas d'accord des fois
on est d'accord ni on y connait pas
d'accord quand même fait beaucoup
voilà ce que je voulais dire par rapport
à l'agriculture
l'agriculture c'est pas le problème je
n'en l'aviculture bien entendu
l'agriculture les agriculteurs c'est pas
le problème
je crois que par rapport à ces assez à
ces problèmes majeurs dans lesquelles
nous sommes
l'agriculture et les agriculteurs sont
des solutions à condition à condition
qu'on les accompagne et qu'on les fasse
évoluer dans leur pratique ou d'un
certaines de leurs pratiques
il faut pas non plus généraliser voilà
je suis je suis intimement convaincu de
cela le gouvernement mène des actions
qui vont dans ce sens je ne suis pas sûr
monsieur le ministre que que ces actions
soient là à la hauteur des enjeux et est
à la hauteur de l'urgence qui est la
nôtre et quand je parle d'urgence et moi
je pense aux agriculteurs aux éleveurs
dont on a tous parlé ici qu'on connaît
tous dans nos territoires qui sont dans
la souffrance
encore une fois voilà ils n'ont pas le
temps de la devoir à 10 ans avançant ils
savent que voilà l'horizon il est il est
tôt à la semaine prochaine pour certains
au mois prochain et au mieux dans
quelques années
voilà donc je pense qu'on en est là
dedans il faut aller beaucoup plus fort
pour notre agriculture pour pour ses
transformations que qu'on ne le fait
voilà le message que je voulais vous
faire passer au nom de mon groupe
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe écologiste
sur l'article 4 il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
voici leur ai vu
un du scrutin numéro 126 sur l'article 4
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs groupe politique est notifiée
à la présidence nombre de votants 343
nombre de suffrages exprimés
252 pour l'adoption 33 et contre 219
le sénat n'a pas adopté les articles de
la proposition de loi ont été
successivement supprimé par le sénat
je constate qu'un vote sur l'ensemble
n'est pas nécessaire puisqu'il n'y a
plus de texte en conséquence la
proposition de loi n'est pas adoptée
[Musique]